my my my  [Music]  can I get you two anything chicken  waffles you should go find someplace  else to go wait in the car region  [Music]  we as of right now are a group of people  who share a common enemy which makes  this what let's call it an alliance  inspiring  [Applause]  you don't want to see what I really am  saying I really like to be back are we  gonna see him no you're not the people  that attacked us fought in unison they  were perfectly coordinated we're not  they make violence look like an art  who are the hey what do they want they  want me she's part of the prophecy  ignore it to work together we got to see  what each other can do okay turn around  you guys to me naked yeah but it'll be  worth it before  [Music]  imagine electricity running through the  whole body you start to feel strong like  you can do anything like you're  breathing in oh you want to roar not  because you're angry because you just  want to let it all out  so roar  snick  you